young miami is one of them yeah for sure
shout out to young miami
i know for a while there when you guys
were dating i felt like you were
threatening a new guy every every couple
weeks on the internet yeah we passed
that stage
we passed that it's cool like you feel
me how's your guys's relationship
nowadays it's my dog still my dad i got
a kid like i ain't you know yeah she's
about to go on tour with jack harlow not
the bitter baby daddy i don't do all
that [ __ ] like that ain't me like it's
cool like you feel me yeah i mean it
plus you guys my daughter's so sweet
like i came to you tonight you know you
guys are both real factors in the music
industry too so you know
does she still get a discount on beats
does qc get the discount if it's for the
city she's never paid for a beat in her
life ever ever ever ever ever ever she's
never played for a beat not for me she's
never played buddy
how proud are you of just how
everything's going for her and uh the
city girls i'm proud of them crazy
where's she from i've really seen where
she from i'm proud like super super
proud yeah so and she's still a good mom
still do good [ __ ] like i was gonna say
what is the key to uh
keeping a cordial co-parenting
relationship
because i'm sure it didn't start this
i'm sure it does it never starts that
way to uh coordinate co-parenting
relationship is just no sex
just cannot have sex with your baby
mama's like you know yeah no like i
can't have like i got a girlfriend too
so you can't have sex with your baby
mamas with a girlfriend cause it's just
she's just like a little it's gotta be
kind of business only right it is
business only yeah yeah keep it cordial
keep it friendly we got a kid involved
yeah very cordial and friendly you feel
me cause you have you have four baby
mamas four you're outside bro for sure
yeah yeah one of them i really don't
know
another three i love them and just be
like